Nous voici donc réunis une fois encore, tous ensemble, devant cette cathédrale au cœur
de notre ville d'Orléans, ville fidèle, rassemblée depuis près de six siècles autour
de la figure de Jeanne, elle qui paraissait la faiblesse même, et qui fut plus forte
que les soi-disant puissants, qu'ils fusent d'un ordre ou d'un autre. Ces soi-disant
puissants ne le lui pardonnèrent jamais. Ce fut une belle idée, monsieur le maire,
que de convier ceux qui exerçèrent cette mission de maire d'Orléans, qu'ils fussent
présents physiquement, ou par la force de l'esprit et de la mémoire, à se rassemblèrent
en ce jour, afin qu'Orléans fût, pour une fois, l'invité de nos fêtes, j'y ai souscrit
immédiatement. Je n'ignore ni le contexte, ni les circonstances, mais il y a toujours
un contexte et des circonstances. Il y a eu récemment, et il y aura bientôt, des échéances
importantes pour notre République. Toutes les échéances suscitent des débats, et je
le sais, nous y défendrons chacun nos convictions en toute clarté. Pour passionner vif et parfois
âpre qu'ils puissent être, nous en savons quelque chose, monsieur le maire. Ces débats
ne doivent jamais nous faire oublier ce qui nous rassemble. Comme ne l'ont pas oublié
le 8 mai dernier, deux présidents de la même République française, présents côte à côte
à l'arc de triomphe, ce monument qui magnifie la victoire, la mémoire de tous ces héros
méconnus innombrables dont nous ne savons pas le nom et qui sont morts pour notre liberté. Ce
qui nous rassemble ici, c'est Orléans, traversant les siècles dans la fidélité à des valeurs
inaltérables. Charles Pégui a décrit dans les premiers Alexandrins qu'il écrivit,
Jeanne, prise d'effroi devant la misère, parlant ainsi de ses contemporains. Les voici repartis
sur la route affameuse. Tous nos efforts sont vains, nos charités sont vaines. Tous ceux-là
que j'aimais sont absents de moi-même. Jean Jaurès évoque à son tour cette même misère.
Pour lui, Jeanne d'Arc, c'était l'imble fille des champs qui avait vu les douleurs et les angoisses
des paysans qui l'entouraient, mais pour qui ces détresses même n'étaient que l'exemple prochain
d'une douleur plus vaste. La douleur de la royauté dépouillée, de la nation envahie. Je le cite
toujours. Elle vivait d'autant mieux avec la grande communauté de la patrie qu'elle pouvait sans
troubles, remplir l'horizon silencieux d'une douleur et d'une espérance qui allaient au-delà.
N'oublions jamais ceci. Jeanne s'est levée pour le droit et contre l'injustice. Son message est un
message de justice. C'est aussi un message de respect, respect dû à tout être humain quel qu'il
soit, d'où qu'il vienne, quelle que soit la couleur de sa peau, qu'il soit ami ou ennemi. C'est ici,
à Orléans, puis à Rouen, qu'André Malraux a proclamé que Jeanne avait donné au monde la seule
figure de victoire qui fût aussi une figure de pitié. En chaque être humain, Jeanne voit toute
l'humanité, l'humanité souffrante, l'humanité bafouée, l'humanité aspirant au bonheur et à la
joie. Ne l'oublions pas, Jeanne se sera battue jusqu'à la dernière heure pour qu'on respecte dans
chaque être humain, chacun, chacune et d'abord les plus faibles, l'humanité. Son étendard est
celui de l'humaine fraternité. Merci à tous. Vive Orléans. Vive la République. Vive la France.